music hey welcome to it's just too easy
it's when we do a story that's just too
easy to ridicule making it too hard to
ignore so in this episode Pete Davidson
he's the nice kid from Saturday Night
Live
he just got a tattoo of Hillary on his
arm when his friends asked him why he
said it was because Hillary was a badass
so now he has something in common with
Hillary they both have an ass on their
arm hers was named Bill see it's just
too easy now I could say that this is
the funniest thing Peter has ever done
but that's just too easy I could say
this is the funniest thing to come out
of SNL this year but that's just too
easy I could just laugh hysterically at
this completely inaccurate likeness of
Hillary but that's just too easy so
maybe it's better to ask why would you
get a tattoo of Hillary when there's so
many other more preferable options like
a gorgeous dolphin look at that or maybe
a delightful unicorn that is so special
or why not just me yeah look at that
it's beautiful everyone should have me
on their body tattoo why someone might
anyway Pete we get it you care you're
morally superior but wooly transparent
in your appeasement tattoos like this
illustrate that decisions based on
feelings always end with something you
really regrets like choosing Hillary's
your candidate because it felt great to
nominate a woman she lost and yet
tattoos are easier to disappear I just
wanted to do this story so we could talk
about tattoos I'm gonna start with you
Dana if you get a tattoo on your body
what tattoo would it be I know well I
think I'm you know I'm not for tattoos
this is pretend yeah I would go with my
main man Jasper I knew it there you go
so we actually had this done this
morning that's great tattoo it doesn't
it hurt terribly yeah it does but that's
why you get drunk you do tons of shots a
couple of pain pills everything's great
Kimberly oh that's every day for you
anyway we won't get into that here your
tattoo if you could uh first of all I
have no tattoos on my body mm-hmm like
Dana I don't do I'm not gonna happen
however yes to play along yes what role
play as the
never wrote I would definitely get ronan
my little munchkin road dog the guy that
the modern eyewear this has tattoos all
over his body and then we kicked him out
of the bill and that would be on my
shoulder yeah
Jesse I'm dying to know what tattoo you
get you know I put a lot of thought into
this Greg and I came up with dr.
Sebastian he's like the most fascinating
man you know that commercial
conversation piece yeah women would like
it men would like it I mean what's not
to like
what if he gets arrested for some
horrible crime what is your tattoo well
I don't think there's much doubt about
if Pete's gonna get Hillary I got to do
something you know as a Fox News guy
what can I do yeah I've got to get a
triple I really wanted the girls on
either side of that because I wanted
like a propaganda special I think it's
actually quite attractive so you I got a
tattoo I actually had this is actually
on me I've got a tattoo of tattoo from
Fantasy Island hanging out from the
Russian hanging out with the russian pop
star duo tattoo there they are all
together and I love their hands up it's
not pleasant you can't tattoo weight
together that was interesting
it is interesting congratulation guy
you've got all the tattoos yes I'd like
to thank Sean or work for ya I gave him
I gave him an unusual mission on Monday
you Roger stone as a tattoo of Nixon on
his back yes won't tell you how I found
out it's interesting
no but it said so
it was called your Saturday night no no
I watched it was a watch some
documentary